pour que vous puissiez voir la lumière en mouvement.
Coca-Cola n'a pas sponsorisé cette recherche. (Rires)
Il se passe beaucoup de choses dans cette vidéo,
je vais donc la décomposer et vous montrer ce qui se passe.
L'impulsion rentre dans la bouteille, notre balle,
avec un paquet de photons qui commence à la traverser
et commence à se disperser à l'intérieur.
De la lumière s'échappe, va sur la table,
et vous commencez à voir cette ondulation.
Une grande partie des photons arrivent finalement au bouchon
et ensuite ils explosent dans toutes les directions.
Vous voyez, il y a une bulle d'air,
et elle rebondit à l'intérieur.
Pendant ce temps, l'ondulation se déplace sur la table,
et à cause du reflet en haut,
vous voyez à l'arrière de la bouteille, après plusieurs images,
les reflets se concentrent.
Si vous prenez une balle ordinaire
et vous lui faites parcourir la même distance et vous ralentissez la vidéo
à nouveau d'un facteur de 10 milliards, savez-vous
combien de temps il vous faudrait rester assis pour regarder la vidéo ?
Une journée, une semaine ? En fait, un an.
Ce serait un film très ennuyeux, (Rires)
d'une balle ordinaire qui se déplace lentement.
Et si nous prenions une nature morte ?
A nouveau vous voyez les ondes inonder la table,
la tomate et le mur à l'arrière.
C’est un peu comme lancer un caillou dans un étang.
J’ai pensé : c’est ainsi que la nature représente une photo,
une image- femto à la fois,
mais bien sûr, nos yeux voient une composition intégrale.
Mais si vous regardez encore une fois la tomate,
vous remarquerez que pendant que la lumière inonde la tomate,
elle continue de luire. Elle ne devient pas sombre.
Pourquoi ? Parce que la tomate est mûre,
et la lumière rebondit à l’intérieur de la tomate,
et en ressort plusieurs trillions de secondes plus tard.
A l’avenir, quand cet appareil photo femto
sera dans votre portable,
vous pourrez aller dans un supermarché
et vérifier si les fruits sont murs sans les toucher.
Comment mes collègues au MIT ont-ils créé cet appareil photo ?
En tant que photographes, vous savez,
si vous prenez une photo avec un temps de pose très court, vous capturez très peu de lumière,
mais nous irons un milliard de fois plus vite
que l’exposition la plus courte que vous utilisez,
nous capturerons à peine la lumière.
En fait, nous envoyons la balle,
ces paquets de photos, des millions de fois,
en enregistrant encore et encore avec une synchronisation très ingénieuse,
nous rassemblons informatiquement
ces giga-octets de données,
pour créer les vidéos-femto que je vous ai montrées.
Nous pouvons prendre toutes les données brutes
et les traiter de façon intéressante.
Superman peut voler.
D’autres héros peuvent devenir invisibles,
mais que diriez-vous d’un nouveau pouvoir pour un futur superhéro :
voir dans les coins ?
L’idée est de projeter la lumière sur la porte.
Elle rebondira, elle entrera dans la pièce,
une partie sera réfléchie sur la porte,
et à nouveau vers l’appareil photo,
et nous pourrions exploiter ces multiples rebondissements de la lumière.
Ce n’est pas de la science-fiction. Nous l’avons vraiment construit.
Sur la gauche, vous voyez notre appareil photo femto.
Il y a un mannequin caché derrière le mur,
et nous allons faire rebondir la lumière sur la porte.
Apres la publication de notre article
sur Nature Communications,
il a été repris par Nature.com,
et ils ont créé cette animation.
(Musique)
Nous allons tirer ces balles de lumière,
qui vont heurter ce mur,
et parce que le paquet de photons,
se dispersera dans toutes les directions,
et certains atteindront le mannequin caché,
qui à son tour dispersera la lumière,
et à nouveau la porte renverra
une partie de cette lumière dispersée,
et une minuscule fraction de photons
reviendra vers l’appareil photo, mais plus intéressant encore,
ils arriveront tous à différents intervalles de temps.
(Musique)
Et puisque nous avons un appareil photo aussi rapide,
notre appareil photo femto a des capacités uniques.
Il a une très bonne résolution,
et il peut voir le monde à la vitesse de la lumière.
De cette manière, nous connaissons les distances, jusqu'à la porte,
mais aussi jusqu'aux objets cachés,
mais nous ne savons pas quel point correspond
à quelle distance.
(Musique)
En projetant un laser nous pouvons enregistrer une photo brute qui,
vue à l’écran, n’a aucun sens,
mais ensuite nous prenons beaucoup de photos comme celle-ci,
des dizaines de photos de ce genre, nous les assemblons,
et nous essayons d’analyser les multiples rebondissements de la lumière,
et de là, pouvons-nous voir les objets cachés ?
Pouvons-nous le voir entièrement en 3D ?
Voilà donc notre reconstruction. (Musique)
(Musique)
(Musique) (Applaudissements)
Il nous faudra encore du temps avant
de sortir tout ceci du labo, mais à l’avenir,
nous pourrons créer des voitures qui évitent les accrochages
avec ce qui est derrière un virage,
ou nous pourrons chercher des survivants dans des conditions dangereuses
en regardant la lumière renvoyée à travers des fenêtres ouvertes,
ou nous pouvons construire des endoscopes qui voient
à l’intérieur de notre corps autour des occlusions,
et aussi pour les cardioscopes.
Mais bien sûr, à cause des tissus et du sang,
c’est assez difficile, donc c’est vraiment un appel
aux chercheurs pour qu’ils commencent à penser à la femto-photographie
en tant que nouvelle solution d’imagerie pour résoudre
les problèmes d’imagerie médicale de la prochaine génération.
Comme pour Doc Edgerton, lui-même scientifique,
la science est devenu un art de la photographie ultra-rapide,
et je me suis rendu compte que tous les giga-octets de données
que nous recueillons à chaque fois
ne sont pas uniquement pour l’imagerie scientifique, nous pouvons faire aussi
une nouvelle forme de photographie informatique
avec intervalles de temps et code couleur,
et nous regardons ces ondulations. Rappelez-vous,
le temps qui passe entre chaque ondulation est seulement
de quelques milliardièmes de seconde.
Mais il y a aussi une chose amusante.
Quand vous regardez ces ondulations sous le bouchon,
les ondulations s’éloignent de nous.
Les ondulations devraient se rapprocher de nous.
Qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
Il s’avère que, vu que nous sommes en train d’enregistrer
quasiment à la vitesse de la lumière,
nous avons des effets bizarres,
et Einstein aurait adoré voir cette photo.
L’ordre dans lequel les choses se passent dans le monde
apparaissent parfois dans l’appareil photo dans l’ordre inverse,
aussi en appliquant les décalages temporels et spatiaux correspondants
nous pouvons corriger cette distorsion.
Que ce soit pour photographier dans des coins,
ou pour créer la prochaine génération d’imagerie médicale,
ou pour créer de nouvelles visualisations,
puisque notre invention est open-source,
toutes les données et les détails sont sur notre site, nous souhaitons
que la communauté des bricoleurs, la communauté des créatifs et des chercheurs
nous montre qu’il faut qu’on arrête d’être obsédé
par les mégapixels des appareils photo, (Rires),
et qu'on commence à se concentrer sur la prochaine dimension d’imagerie.
Il est grand temps. Merci. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)